um today I want to talk a little bit
about how panas and DK are integrating
more de with
P um and Apache arrow in general and how
this is changing for projects pretty
deeply
um first a little bit about me um I am
currently working at coil um coil a
company where we deploy DK um in the
cloud but I work on our open source team
and focus mostly on the development of
TK um a couple of the things I'm showing
today is something I've been working on
for months now um I am a member of the
pandas cor team for like close to 3
years
now um and was like involved in the
arrow integration that we published at
the 2.0 release a couple of months ago
earlier this
year
um I'm assuming that most people here
know
pandas um it's a data analysis Library
um that is a little bit
popular um the second part of the talk
will focus on um how we can scale
handers to bigger work Lots um one
possible option is um dusk specifically
the dask data frame API um I won't focus
on anything else today um just the data
frame integration um dask in General
Scales High data libraries and
specifically pnets which is a big part
of what I'm focusing on
at um we have a lot of topics today we
have a lot of ground to cover um we will
start with like Arrow integration as um
a backing of data frames um and we'll
focus a little bit more on strings than
the other D types because they offer a
lot of
benefits then we move over to copy and
right which is a new feature in pandas
that will hopefully for one speed of
performance and to make the behavior of
the API more consistent and easier to um
identify for
users the third thing is specific to
dusk um shuffling is something that you
need in a distributed system that
doesn't really matter for panas at all
um there's a lot of work going on in D
to make this more efficient more stable
generally uh a better user
experience and then what I'm currently
working on is a query Optimizer for task
data
frames um there are some loose plans to
also adapt this for pandas in the future
but we want to First focus on to make
this work for D before we um think about
anything
else um I have a couple of demos today
um they will mostly use dask because
dask demos a lot better than pandas
simply since the virs are take longer at
a larger
we will start with an example that
illustrates how D behaved like 6 months
ago um the query I'm running it's not
super important it has to merges which
which involves a lot of
shuffling and a group by aggregation D
was historically not very good at
this um and we will like shortly see
why um these are the operations that we
focusing on um to make them more
efficient um in the end we will see how
this changed over the last couple of
months um so on the right side what we
can see here is um in the top um this is
what's going on in our D cluster this is
basically a pandis like workflow
distributed
way um a d cluster is generally happy if
you don't see a lot of white and you
don't see a lot of rep which is both
things that we have quite a lot
here um
so this is a workload that's like not
ideal um it operates on 100 GB of data
um on 20 machines so in theory this
should be pretty quick but because of
some historic issues historical issues
of TK um this takes a long time and we
can see how the red grows um down here
is the memory usage on the cluster this
also goes up quite a lot um if you wait
until the workflow finishes then we will
run into the r area here iMed and in the
end kill some workers which is not ideal
but I only have 40 minutes so we don't
have 2 minutes to wait here and see how
the cluster feels
itself um a lot of the things that
happened in pandas and dusk over the
last year year and a half um have
enabled us to get rid of this and we
will later see how um we can run this
workflow 10 times faster um with a lot
less memory
pressure um but before we can get there
we have to build some
Theory going back to the slide
um first part is the Apache Arrow
integration in pandas and dask um Arrow
initially was founded like in 2015 by
the pandas founder as
well and over the last like three or
four years the pandas project moved a
lot into the direction of better
integrating arrow with its API um and
now we will see what this means for
users the whole talk assumes that you
are using 2.0 or later um anything
before that is like a long time ago for
development
Cycles um my opinion the biggest
advantage of Pache arrow for pandas is
that it has an efficient string data
type
implementation historically panas used n
object e type to represent strings um
which is for one slow and two super
memory inefficient and like memory just
blows up if you have a lot of n objects
but there isn't really an efficient
string data type in Num that we could
have used alternatively that's why we
fell back to
up Arrow changes that for us a lot um
they have a string data type that's
contigous in memory um so we don't waste
any bytes that we don't need and it's
also super fast to operate
on Arrow comes a lot with compute
functionality um for stuff that has
historically not been available in n
um they have a lot of compute
functionality that you can dispatch to
so we can and will rebout some of our
custom implementations um to reduce the
maintainance burden and also just
dispatch more
efficiently I think most people know
this if you have a pandas integer column
that's not byb backed and you try to
insert a missing value um you will lose
the integer column and it will get
upcast to float which especially in
finance finance history is very annoying
um Arrow also changes that Arrow has
nullability by default for every D type
so if you want to insert missing values
you will just keep the DP
consistent um also we can just represent
a lot more data types like if you have
fights or decimals or nested data like
structs or lists all of this is object
in panas but in Arrow we have specific
data types for that so for one the
implementation is more efficient and two
memory usage is a lot lot lot
then it would be
object um this is the biggest Advantage
at the moment for us
um all these different data types and
have a consistent you act um if you do a
lot of numerical calculation and you
have only float columns then Arrow won't
help very much since numai is very very
optimized in that area um but as soon as
you have different data types that don't
fit into the integer of load um area
then Arrow becomes way more valuable to
users
um also there's another thing like
there's polars now dctb ppar um they're
all backed by the AO data model so if
you want to move your data from one data
frame implementation to another using
this with arrow is zero copy going from
num to Arrow might be zero copy but it's
probably not so you will you will
trigger copies
some um this is a quick view into the
future um pandas 3.0 which is the ex
expect to come out early next year will
start to infer Arrow strings by default
so you won't get n object anymore except
if you have like mixed columns if you
have strings and integers then you will
still end up with n object but if you
have columns that are purely strings
then this will just be an arrow back
string without any like user effort this
will just be the new default um this new
string data type will behave as not by
object so we change the semantics of
error a little bit to just reduce the
migration burden on users
um so just the same code statement um
you inst instantiate a data frame with
like string columns right now you get
object D type and in P 3.0 you will get
an arrow back string D type um no change
required
hopefully this is already available
starting with pis 2.1 not 2.0 um there's
an
option that will enable this new
behavior um so if you want to get
this Behavior right now you can just
turn the option on um assuming you're on
pandas 2.1 or later and then you will
get rid of
my
um another advantage over like casting
yourself is that all IO readers will
automatically use this D type so if you
for example reach from par files right
now you would go to object and then you
would have to cast back to Arrow strings
which is slow and like memory in
efficient and if you set this option all
of this will happen by default there
won't be um object um stream laun
anymore dusk is a very similar
implementation um but we already using
them by default um we made the switch um
already so if you instantiate a d data
frame you won't end up with n object
anymore um we have seen better
performance but to be honest most D
users don't care that much about
performance they care more about memory
stability um which is a huge Improvement
like we've seen memory usage on like
data sets with a couple of string
columns like reduced by 50 to 60% um if
you have more string um heavy data sets
then this um decrease will be idea we
will in a few seconds see a demo how
this looks
like as I said it's used by default it's
it's July um so if you're on a new Das
version you will get this behav by
default
yeah dusk has an option convert string
this is on by default so if you want to
see the difference between
um of variant then we'll have to turn it
off
obviously um so if you do if you load
this now um
then I probably should have restart the
CL
um we will see how quickly the memory
resarch grows here also the reading is
pretty uh slow because the string to
Arrow string for object conversion is
especially um disadvantage in multi
thread
environments um we can see that our
cluster here um the memory usage is
growing these orange bars says that we
are in a critical area where Das starts
building to dis which is something you
won't want um because that will just
make you
slow I will kill that data for
now and restart my
client um so that we don't have to wait
until this is finished I'm spilling to
this is very slow so if we set this
option to
True um then we will notice two
different things for one the reading is
way faster because the conversion from
parket to Arrow to dusk is just zero
copy and the even more impressive thing
is like the bars down here um there's no
memory pressure on our CL It just fits
very easily um this either saves cost or
brings you a lot of stability
um we only have like 4.5 gigs in here
previously we had over 10 um so this is
roughly at 50% 50 to 60%
decrease um the impressive thing here is
that we only have three string cols
everything else is like not touched by
this option at all um the categories
here have some string columns as well
but they have like three flags like yes
no and na so the arrow strings won't
really matter here
it's just these three string columns
that reduce our memory usage by 50% um
if you have more string columns then
this will be
moreing so we'll just scale the C for
the next
time the second bigger thing that we
expect um for 3.0 is that we will change
copy and VI rules in P um right now this
is a pretty big mess in our opinion
users might disagree but I haven't found
any
um we want to have more consistent copy
and B semantics in pandas and we call
this copy and right this is something
that's popular More in the low level
World and a bit tricky in pandas but I
think we can make this work or I like to
call it like getting rid of the setting
of copy
warning um the setting of copy warning
is like an old friend for most kindless
uses I guess um or a foe I don't know
like I've ran into this like on my first
week using panas and I really didn't
understand what was going on until I
started maintaining the indexing engine
panas so yeah I'm sorry for everyone had
to suffer through that um copy and right
will change panas in a way that the
setting with copy warning will go away
it won't be necessary anymore um so all
the blog posts that are out there trying
to explain you do what is Happ with copy
warning as can be deleted
up um what this does right now is if you
subset a data frame um this is a buo
mask um like if you filter for something
that's greater than one then this will
trigger a copy panders thinks that you
might have wanted to update DF as well
so we try to be intelligent here and so
we tell you yeah that this doesn't work
but most users probably don't care that
the F isn't update um they just want to
update subsite and then they are
fine um so what most people do like at
least to my experience is they add a
copy in that line which will trigger
another copy um it's a little bit
annoying if your data frame is large
like if it only has a couple of rows
then doesn't
matter
so what we are aiming for is that every
data frame or series that is Created
from another pandas
object behaves as a copy um we don't
actually do a copy so there won't not
every operation will create a copy but
they will try to behave as it would be a
copy so if you try to update this new
object um the parent won't be updated
anymore even if it's a view
oniv um so there won't be an operation
in panas that will update two objects at
once that won't be possible anymore um
you only update the object that you're
operating
on um our opinion this is a couple of
advantages um the user experience is
more consistent um and simpler you don't
have to worry anymore about copies and
Views panders will just take care of
this for you and we try to be as
efficient as possible and you only have
copy when it's
necessary as I said setting of copy war
is in the past then um we already have a
working implementation for copy and
right that's basically finished um and
the setting of copy warning doesn't
matter there anymore um like I can
complete test spe runs
on um there won't be a confusion anymore
if you are mutating two objects or three
or four or five or only one um copy and
right will take care of that for
you
another advantage that I personally like
even
more is that we don't have to do
defensive copies anymore at the moment
in pandas if you have a data frame that
has like 50 columns and you drop one
column
um you might expect that this is a view
and we just like remove that column from
the air frame and give it back a new
object but but that's not what we do
like we copy all the columns like a deep
copy of the
data if you then like rename all your
columns don't touch the data at all you
again deep copy of the data this goes
through basically all operations that
don't change the length of your data
frame um every operation even copies the
The Columns you don't touch like as
typing one column you copy all the
others this is because if you wouldn't
do that and you would do an in place
modification afterwards you might update
20 objects at once and I wish you good
luck bu that it's not f um this is one
of the reasons why copy and right is on
some operations very very fast compared
to the previous
ination like you have a rename here and
then an assign drop as type reset index
set index none of this actually changes
the length of your data like NPI
triggers copies if you change the length
of your data but none of these actually
do um the current implementation copy is
for all of these stat um if copy and
right we get rid of these defensive
copies so the running time is constant
it doesn't matter anymore how long your
data frame is it will just be like some
metadata um cost that happen under the
hood but your data is
untouched this won't help if you do like
group ey aggregations and stuff like
that because that do need copies anyway
but if you do a lot of
like modifying of your data frame before
you actually aggregate at some point
then this will speed up your code a lot
one of the cor Rand is on a like
proprietary code base and he saw like 60
to 70% performance improvements over the
current impation that they
using it was also running for like 10
minutes not like we got down from 2
seconds to one that wouldn't be that
impressive
um we'll get back to this later but you
already can try this out
um the implementation is basically
finished there aren't any bucks that we
aware of like there might be some that
that we don't know about but um from our
point of view this is finished and could
go live now but we have to wait for
prund sorry you said this is coming in
one or is it already this is available
in 2.0 and you can use it I would
recommend upgrading to 2.1 though and
with 3.0 it will be the
default there won't be a non cop and V
so um if you like updating multiple
objects at once you have to find a
different solution
um we will now move over the dusk data
frame a bit in a bit more
detail um the theme of this is like that
dask data frame is pass now um we will
see in a little bit why this is
true um we will specifically talk about
a new Shuffle algorithm and how we
introduce C optimization to last data
frames um so that we can just avoid
doing unnecessary work
and then we'll watch another demo um how
this looks in comparison to the previous
impementation
so we start with the shuffle
algorithm the previous Shuffle algorithm
that was the default until earlier this
year was a task based Shuffle algorithm
and what we can see here we just had a
bunch of inputs and a bunch of outputs
that were on different workers and to
get to the output State we had to create
um a lot of intermediate tasks
um this scal with n * m where n is the
number of input partitions and M is the
number of output partitions so in the
worst case you had a quadratic like
growth of intermediate task and if you
have to schedule like millions of small
tasks then the DK schedul will just Peck
and like slower cluster down by orders
of
magnitudes the new shuffling algorithm
gets more or less completely rid of this
intermediate layer there's only one task
doesn't matter how much how big your
data frame is how many partitions you
have
um all this complexity is Now hidden
away in a different system that doesn't
strain the schu and it's also L faster
in general but we also not paining the
schedule
anymore
um so this means for us that we have
significantly improved
performance like you can now utilize all
resources in our cluster before that if
you had a huge cluster and just like in
a huge data frame we were probably
utilizing 5% of your available CPU now
we're more at 60 to 70 and the remaining
stuff is like do by this this
R so does that mean your
multi dusk dusk has always been
multicore and multile machines sing
machine yes yes um you can utilize all
your resources on if you have an HPC
with 100 course D can make use of all of
them so are you centralizing them how
youing the
check the task are just the input task
are just sending the part the data to
the output um like workers without
telling the schedule about this this is
hidden away in a in a system that's not
like strain schedule as much okay so
directly to yes we are not going through
like scheduling millions of small
tasks um the P2P Shuffle this is the new
Shuffle algorithm you can see here that
data usage like memory usage is very
very low um we can Shuffle the Conant
memory while this one is packed at like
orange which means that we spilling to
this this is the great part here and
this is a dashboard like you wanted to
see on the right side like less wide um
and all workers are constantly busy
while this here is like a lot of white
which means that workers are idling and
don't have anything to
um we generally can now Shuffle data
conent memory previously this was
growing linearly and at some point like
your cluster was killed if you didn't
account for
that um the blue line is the new P2P
Shuffle um it's just
like constant at 5 GB and then when we
unpack there is a small Spike this was
actually a p which is fixed
now and the old task based shuffling
just goes up linearly and then 25 GB is
yeah this per work actually quite a
lot um so this will ince increased
stability um by a lot compared to the by
previous implementation of task base
job this has been enabled in March this
year and it's now since used as the
default um we don't we haven't seen many
workflows that actually want to use Tas
bade shuffling most of our users um
switched over um to P2P Shuff
the thing that we're currently working
on that's not yet enabled by default is
um cury planning in
dask historically dask was just
executing what you gave it so if you
were like reading a whole data set and
selecting one column D was reading the
whole data set and then dropping all the
others which is especially annoying if
you're reading from S3 or somewhere
where latency is High um and data
transfer is not super fast um we are
slowly getting rid of all of these
problems
now um we will just quickly start with a
short example and see what the CER
Optimizer can do for you before we go
into more technical details and then
look at the
demo um so this is a c like someone
would might write it we read a whole
paret file filter for like one specific
value do a sum and then you select one
value um that's currently would still
read all of your all of your color all
of your rows and then it will do
everything in memory if your data set is
large this is pretty
annoying so the qu Optimizer what a
query Optimizer normally does is it
looks at your query identifies which
columns you'll need um in this case it's
X and ID and restrict the read from
Storage to these
columns um but that's not all we can do
like we are still aggregating um ID and
X which is something like we don't need
so we can move the projection of X in of
the Su so that we only have to like
aggregate one column not
two given that's a small Advantage but
if you have lots of colums before that
um might quite make a
difference um but we still reading all
rows for these two columns which also is
not necessary because Park supports
filters in the I so that you don't have
to load all data in
memory um so this is something you can
do as well this is a bit tricky because
this is not always efficient um if your
data is not sorted for for example there
is no information about your data
available this might slow you down but
it will still keep your memory usage
lower significantly lower in this
case the change is pretty small um the
API mirrors the D data frame API it's
still a separate project but we will
change that hopefully soon and then it
will be integrated with th data frame
and um it's on my default but right now
it's a different project that just
mirors the um T SC from API and like
optimized step is injected between
actually like getting the query and
executing
it
um some background why we're doing this
now um historically what do was good at
is flexibility on the scheduler and
smartly scheduling tasks to your
different workers um so task was able to
do to basically create task graphs from
every random query you can think of like
if the this was very complex and had
like different dependencies on each
other that was able to figure this out
um this was like our main selling point
against something like spark but if you
do SQL like stuff this these things
don't matter as much because the queries
are can only get so
comp so dusk dusk always always had this
like physical um optimization plan while
spark had the high level logical plan
that was just dropping unnecessary
work and that's why now why we building
this into dusk um took a long while to
be honest but now we are finally getting
there um this will make us a lot faster
on like common workloads um we will in
know see in a little bit how much um we
actually can improve performance
here
um all the things that we're doing here
could be done by the user obviously like
quy reordering is nothing that's like
magic but most users either don't want
to think about this which is totally
understandable or if you have thousands
of columns in a very complex Cy
optimizing this by hand is like
pain um so this is where the cerer
optimizer comes in handy it just does
this automatically for you and you don't
have to think that much about writing
efficient code anymore still have to
think a
little so now we can look at a quick
example um I prepared like two D
clusters here each of them has 20
workers um on the right side um is the
old version which uses task based
shuffling and the current D data frame
implementation we will give this one a
little bit of a head story and on the
right side is the new version with P2P
the new Shuffle algorithm and the query
Optimizer and now we can start as
well and the first thing that we can see
here we have like 62,000 um hopefully
that's readable uh 62,000 tasks of this
intermediate layer that I was talking
about earlier which is quite a lot um we
can see that over here the whole query
this is the optimized query with P2P
shuffling um just has maybe 15,000 tasks
in total um so only the shuffle step has
four times as many tasks as the other
query complete complete other
query um this is connected to the wrong
dashboard that's
interesting um but what you can see here
like um the right side is already like
finished and basically chilling in the
locker room while the left side is still
pretty busy and like if you want to wait
for another minute and you will see that
this will get into memory problems and
slow down even
further um what we've seen is like this
is on 100 GB um this is a size that you
could Benchmark pretty good on um we've
seen like 5 to 10 x improvements um if
you increase the size to 1 TB dask data
frame was either not running anymore
because it was running out of memory
this space was used stuff like that or
we were like 50 to 100 times faster so
if we would scale this out to 10 terab
100 tab like DK probably wouldn't be
able to handle this anymore while our
dask expression implementation is just
running along happily obviously get
slower with more data but we can still
complete the queries
easily um things users can do now um
that will hopefully improve their life
and the ux and we can enable copy and
right
um that's just a simple flag and then
you will use the new semantics um I
would run the test speed after this um
some things
change um then you can enable the INF
string option that just will give you
Arrow back strings by default
um copy and right is available since 2.0
um info strings are available since 2.1
um so you need the new newest version
for
that and if you're D data frame user um
if you do anything new we would
recommend switching over like it's
currently a separate library but we will
move this into D data frame at some
point hopefully not too far in the
future um it's just a plain python
Library it doesn't bring in any
dependencies so it's an easy
[Applause]
install